[Music]
we work very much just like kids being
kids on a set
why was my memory from the first from
philosopher's stones i just learned how
to play slam you know what we did a lot
of as well was that
[Music]
they probably made their jobs harder for
themselves by letting us have as much
fun as we had because it distracted us
from
you know the work we were supposed to be
doing and for the other viewers
trapped
like a big problem was like throughout a
take our attention would like would wane
and come and go they say a line and then
they'd smile at the camera or they were
just so happy to be in a harry potter
film that they couldn't contain their
excitement long enough to focus on an
entire scene
think of that powerful memory
make it
the happiest you can remember
it feels like no time has passed
and loads of times past
i think this is the perfect time to sit
down with everyone and reminisce
the thing that scared me the most
was the implication that the most
meaningful thing in our life was done
and there's something so joyous about
seeing everyone
and be like
there wasn't though one of the
highlights of my part was when i had to
pretend to be hermione pretending to be
better i don't like to be kept waiting
i've still got the teeth actually i'll
put them in if you want
my sister has children who have been
around 10 11 12 and i said moth i don't
know about this voldemort what you're
being asked to play voldemort
you've got to do it
i wouldn't be the person i am without so
many people here
it's a very overwhelming thing because
i've watched you go up and i've seen
kind of every stage of your life
when things get really dark and times
are really hard there's something about
harry potter that makes life richer it's
a strong bond that will always happen
we're family and we will always be part
of each other's life
[Music]
[Music]
you